Salut ! Il y a une formule très précise qui apparemment permet de calculer le "Blue Monday",
c'est-à-dire, le jour où tu seras le plus dépressif dans l'année.
C'est Cliff Arnall qui est à l'origine de cette équation,
il était professeur à l'université de Cardiff.
Et il a créé une formule très précise:
(W plus D moins d) fois T puissance Q sur M multiplié fois Na.
Alors W c'est la météo,
Grand D, c'est le taux d'endettement,
Petit d, c'est le salaire mensuel de la personne,
Grand T, c'est le temps qui s'est écoulé depuis Noel,
Grand Q, c'est le temps passé depuis le dernier gros échec de cette personne,
M, c'est son niveau de motivation
et Na, c'est la nécessité d'agir.
même dans de la presse plus sérieuse, ou dans des journaux un peu plus sérieux.
Alors que cette formule n'a aucun, aucun, aucun fondement scientifique !
Il y a des experts en science qui l'ont appelé "la bêtise absolue" !
Parce que en fait cette équation, elle a pris des proportions un peu démesurées,
c'est ce qu'il se passe parfois avec les pseudo-sciences.
Et du coup, l'université de Cardiff a publié dans un premier temps un communiqué,
en précisant "qu'en fait, il était juste professeur à mi-temps",
Et la réalité finale elle est très drôle: en fait ils avaient juste fait ça pour une campagne marketing,
et qui encore aujourd'hui propagent cette équation qui n'a pas de sens !
Comme quoi, si vous voulez faire une équation vous même, vous prenez des grosses lettres,
vous donnez un sens aux grosses lettres, et puis vous publiez ça, ça peut le faire.
Et moi de mon côté, je vous donne rendez vous après demain.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Une vidéo tout les deux jours jusqu'au 30 août.
Ciao !
[musique]